-Good evening, I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
How's everybody doing tonight?
That is so good to hear.
Let's get to the news.
President Donald Trump attacke
Fox News on Twitter yesterda
and said, quote, "Can't believ
how badly Fox News
is doing in the ratings."
Really? You can't?
You were their number-one show
and you got cancelled.
And now Fox News is basicall
Disney+
without the "Mandalorian."
Anybody want to watch
"Snow Dogs"?
White House press secretar
Kayleigh McEnany said this wee
that President Trump plans t
veto the $740 billion
defense spending bill despit
passing Congress
with a veto-proof majority
Said Trump, "[ As Trump ] Ho
many times do I have to say it
I don't understand how any o
this works!"
[ Normal voice ] A massive
winter storm passed throug
the Northeast last night and
blanketed New York City
with eight inches of know,
which means it's time for ou
new segment
"A Joke My Door Man Wrote.
That's right,
a massive winter storm blanketed
New York City with eight inche
of snow
and De Blasio's so dumb,
he peppered the streets.
-This has been
"A Joke My Door Man Wrote.
-My door man's name is
John Mulaney.
[ Distant chucking ]
Russian President Vladimir Putin
said today
that he has not received the
coronavirus vaccine yet
because the version being
distributed in Russia
is not recommended for peopl
over 60 years old.
And he's pretty sure he's either
42 or 79,
so he'll skip it just
to be safe.
According to a new study,
college students are drinkin
less than normal during th
coronavirus pandemic.
Said students, "Yeah, these days
I'm pretty much done
after my 10th White Claw."
A man in Scotland was recently
jailed for violating
coronavirus restrictions after
traveling by jet ski
to an island off the coast o
Britain to see his girlfriend,
though I think it was
probably punishment enough
riding on a jet ski in Scotlan
in the middle of December.
Organizers of Times Squares'
New Year's Eve celebration
announced this week that singe
Gloria Gaynor
will perform her famous song
"I Will Survive"
in honor of essential worker
because she's...
breaking up with them?
And finally, today
was Wright Brothers Day,
and who would've guessed
all those years ago
that it would actually be more
dangerous to fly now.
And that was the monologue